a king there's no friends  lowly followers at fault in their  chapter of my life is done this Prince I  spent my days drinking clowning  now I find myself the king choose your  steps wise dear brother they have their  own kingdoms behind their eyes I need  men around me I can trust  you are my friend I will come with you  now you'll be washed over vinyls here  the different King France is taunting us  they were my father's enemies not mine  the screams of young men  so led me to sleep at night you will not  topple this king henry v of england you  so underestimate  are you ready for it awaits us  what is bloody Pensacola's this is hope  theses forms  do you feel a sense of achievement  surrender to me  King of England are you scared  already I can feel the weight if this  crowd I wear  you